here's corey booker because you know we
got this katanji brown jackson she's
getting confirmed it's very exciting for
these people she doesn't know what a
woman is
but okay fine she's just going to be on
the supreme court well cory booker in
another one of his theatrical moments
just finished the vote uh
catanji brown jackson has now been
confirmed by the senate to be a justice
on the supreme court
and i think there are a lot of people
who can appreciate this that
there is a lot of
hurt in this world there's a lot of
private pain and
personal
injury and
we live in a nation with
acres of ground that's been watered with
tears and
sadness
but today is
a mountain of joy today is a day for
celebration today i rejoice
i
i cry tears of joy and i just want to
thank god and thank
this extraordinary woman for persevering
through all of life's challenges for
overcoming
all of life's obstacles and now rising
and knowing as when i talk to her she
knows that we
as a nation rise
rise with her
is he literally selfie videoing himself
from the closet like is he he's gay
right like isn't that a thing like he's
gay or i'm not i don't mean not to be
mean like gay is spectacular everyone's
gay now you better be gay oh my god it's
wonderful
he's just such an overly emotional
theater kid that's what he is he's a
seventh grade theater child what people
thought he was going to be president you
clowns he's an actor he's nothing he's a
ridiculous actor but here's noted wizard
kamala harris on the excitement over
katanji brown jackson
you know there's so much about what's
happening in the world now
that is presenting some of the worst
of
this moment in human
behaviors and then we have a moment like
this
that i think reminds us that there is
still so much yet to accomplish and that
we can accomplish okay so she just
throws some words together it's not even
worth it and i do the reason i really
wanted to show that was because of the
mask thing why she's wearing a mask
she's outdoors we all know that the
masks are all [ __ ] these people are
all liars and buffoons and frauds
all that being said kamala stay with the
mask i think you should be in a mask all
the time perhaps even one over your
whole head
that would be better that would be
better now
i just want to say something about the
katandi brown jackson thing look it as i
had judge andrew napolitano on the show
last week if you if you did not see it
we talked a bit about the confirmation
hearing and his position
even though it was obvious that he
doesn't really love her and her judicial
positions
the judge's position was that it's the
president's right and duty obviously to
nominate a supreme court justice and
barring sort of anything like truly
crazy in their voting history or in
their decision-making history that in
essence
the senate is supposed to confirm them
that's sort of how it's supposed to work
that that really is it it's the
president's decision and unless there's
some red flag that is so extraordinary
that you basically move on it now
unfortunately that's not really the way
it works well unfortunately or or
fortunately that's not really the way it
works because everything obviously has
become hyper-politicized and actually
really that all started about 30 years
ago with a guy by the name of joe biden
robert bork if you haven't heard it or
watching the video on that
but
this woman
she literally does not know what a woman
is she said she could not tell you what
a woman is because she's not a biologist
now relative to what's going on in the
country right now with everything i've
covered on the show today and the
endless craziness related to gender and
everything else it might be important
that a supreme court justice have some
sense of what a woman is
it might be relevant right